mark zuckerberg war im harvard neuling
mit einer begabung fürs programmieren
weniger als patient war es leider
multimilliardär mit dem baby gesicht v
der mit dem präsidenten zusammen
und ich habe mark dazu gebracht hat und
krawatte zu tragen ich glaube die
meisten leute haben die größe von
facebook noch nicht wirklich verstanden
und wie schnell es gewachsen ist das
ziel ist offensichtlich eine
allgegenwart mark zuckerberg möchte dass
alle diesen service nutzen
die seite hat mittlerweile über 900
millionen nutzer man kann nicht
unterschätzen wie getrieben sagte burke
ist er ist genauso visionär steve jobs
wirklich als genauso einflussreich
erweisen wie bill gates trotz des
erfolgs lieferte sich sachsenburg
erbitterte kämpfe und prozesse
er wollte seine eigene team
kontrollieren und wenn er gegen jemanden
vorgeht wird er ihn vernichten wir haben
drei monate mit marke arbeitet und
wurden hier das licht geführt wir hatten
keine ahnung dass er an einem
konkurrenzprodukt
er hat einen totalen krieg gegen seine
größten konkurrenten geführt die
beziehung zwischen facebook und google
ist ziemlich einfach sie mögen sich
einfach nicht und zuckerberg geriet
unter beschuss weil er die grenzen der
privatsphäre nutzer haben weniger
kontrolle über private informationen sie
wissen nicht genau wie ihre infos
weitergegeben werden handelt nicht nur
mit einem stück technik er handelt mit
menschen und ihrem verhalten und der tat
das ohne viel darüber nachzudenken
sie haben diese riesige datenbank mit
informationen über uns angehäuft weil
wir ihnen vertraut haben die frage ist
also sollen wir ihnen weiter vertrauen
wir treffen unsere entscheidung bei
facebook nicht zu optimieren was im
nächsten jahr passieren
darauf vorzubereiten in einer welt zu
leben in der jede produkterfahrung
soziale alles von facebook angesetzt
[Musik]
ich glaube unser ziel war keine online
community sondern eine art spiegel der
echten gemeinschaft die in wirklichen
leben existiert monas zuckerberg wir
denken wir kennen ihn beide sein leben
im oscar prämierten film the social
network gesehen das porträt war
schonungslos einen super nerd
halsabschneider brillant wo aber sozial
ich verstehe nicht welchem teil aber
stimmte das auch immer freunde er ist
ein ziemlich sozialer typ ich glaube das
letzte mal habe ich 879 freunde auf
facebook
das hier ist der wahre mark zuckerberg
2005 in facebooks ernster zentrale von
jungen filmemachern geträumt
3 millionen nutzer und seit wann gibt es
facebook nicht so lange
[Musik]
währen zuckerberg die privatsphäre der
nutzer ausreizt entschied er sich gegen
die teilnahme an unserem programm
2004 gründete er facebook im alter von
19 jahren mit facebook inzwischen hat
der 28-jährige ein geschätztes vermögen
von 15 5 milliarden dollar angehäuft
max mission war von anfang an menschen
zu verbinden sie basierte auf diese
theorie dass die welt ein besserer ort
wäre wenn sie stärker verbunden wäre
aber es gibt viele überraschungen wenn
man wirklich tief in die geschichte von
facebook eintaucht die größte ist die
eigenwillige persönlichkeit von mark
zuckerberg
die tiefe seiner überzeugungen
[Musik]
1984 geboren wuchs er in jobs terry am
hudson aus in einer wohnsiedlung
nördlich von new york city david
kirkpatrick recherchierte zwei jahre
lang für ein buch über sascha burg und
facebook mit dem titel the facebook
effect er stammt aus einer unglaublichen
unterstützenden familie in der er der
einzige sohn war er hat drei schwestern
also war er eine art drin ich glaube
seine eltern haben ihn sogar den prinzen
genannt und er wurde dementsprechend
behandeln er ist ein typ ohne probleme
mit dem selbstvertrauen computer talent
von anfang an brachte sich sascha bert
die komplizierte computersprache sieglos
platz in der neunten klasse entwickelte
er eine digitale version des brettspiels
risiko journalist jose antonio vargas
interviewte zuckerberg für sein new
yorker magazin profil tatsächlich
angewandt sagt ned geschaffen ein
modernes instant messaging system für
die familie damit wie computer
miteinander reden konnten
so ein kind gewesen
als er seine highschool satt hatte
beschloss er auf die exit school zu
gehen wirklich weil er einfach mehr
herausforderungen wollte in der
exklusiven ex rtl erstellten zuckerberg
und sein freund adam die angelo eine
musik website
sie sollte so sein dass sie deine
vorlieben erkennt und sie war sehr
beliebt noch bevor er mit facebook
anfiel
er lehnte angebote von microsoft und
anderen ups in apps für weit über eine
million dollar zu verkaufen
viele namhafte unternehmen wollten ihn
direkt aus exeter rekrutieren sie eine
tech version eines allstar athleten dem
wasserwerk war unbeeindruckt und
entschied sich 2002 statt dessen für
harvard
wo ist nicht lange dauert sr probleme
bekam zuckerberg hatte sich in die
computer der uni und bilder von schülern
zusammen nico das carls
stellvertretender redakteur bei business
insider dort kommen so ein bisschen am
ingolstädter ist gerade in seinem ersten
jahr in harvard etwas erfunden das
facemash als eine art horw toren noch
für die uni und dann führte die seite
eine ganze liste von harvard studenten
welche die attraktivste waren nach
schönheit zu erzielen
war irgendwie ein bisschen eklig ist
verweigerte die leute offensichtlich
fühlten sie sich verspottet oder
bloßgestellt
es war eine der ersten großen
erfahrungen die mag mit
datenschutzproblemen macht
schloss die seit die harvard verwaltung
klagte ihn wegen sicherheitsverletzung
verletzung von urheberrechten und
verletzung der privatsphäre
aber facemash war zu dem zeitpunkt schon
einen campus sensation zuckerberg hatte
gleich in die zeit als er ärger mit
dieser fiesen webb hatte bekam baute er
ein anderes dieses tool das super
beliebt war
ich kann mir vorstellen dass ein paar
schlaflose nächte hatte und sich sorgen
machte wie schlimm diese sache werden
würde aber erleichtert als alles vorbei
war und war aber auch unglaublich
neugierig was er als nächstes machen
könnte wenn du ein genie mit genialen
freundin bist und in irgend einem
schlafsaal sitzt sieht die welt wie ein
großer glücklicher ort aus wenn er in
diese datenbank kommst die welt der
datenbanken veränderte sich damals
rasant
bei der bloomberg businessweek das
internet war 2004 eine ganz andere welt
ein fenster sieht man dass ein soziales
netzwerk technisch funktionieren die
sollte hängt sich immer auch
unzuverlässig nochmals voll mit werbung
an der harvard lernte zuckerberg den
schüler und zukünftigen geschäftspartner
eduardo
ist einer der wenigen die herrin über
die anfänge von facebook interviewt
haben
traf mark zuckerberg bei einer jüdischen
bruderschaft
war nicht wirklich lustig war eine etwas
seltsame soziale umgebung nicht
schlechte partys meistens nur jungs also
trafen sich überall nur einmal in dieser
szene und sie wurden ziemlich schnell
freunde weil sie beide eine art
außenseiter waren
wurden drei oberschicht jungs aus
hamburg aufmerksam die eine social
networking seite namens harvard
connection war eine idee die ich ende
2002 als junior im college
die drei bastelten seit fast einem jahr
an der seite zwei ihrer programmierbaren
abgesprungen und sie brauchten dringend
einen neuen partner
wir sind keine computer programmierer
von beruf oder so wir brauchten einen
echten programmierer um das wir uns zu
schreiben
und wir dachten mag wäre dieser türkei
also gingen sie auf sascha bertow
gebirge
der war begeistert aufgeregt und seine
augen strahlten
wo erst dann geschah löste einen
erbitterten streit darüber aus wie
facebook eigentlich entstanden war die
details werden in e mails zwischen
zuckerberg und dem havag connect
zu beginn war zuckerberg noch als
eigentlich ich habe eure sachen gelesen
und ich denke die umsetzung sollte nicht
allzu lange dauern können darüber reden
wenn ich morgen abend alles hochgefahren
habe dann fing zuckerberg ami das
projekt zu verzögern der täter dezember
entschuldigt dass ich nicht erreichbar
war ich habe gerade euere verpassten
anrufe gesehen ich habe an einem problem
gearbeitet zehnter dezember die woche
war ziemlich stressig konnte noch nicht
wirklich an der seite arbeiten oder
darüber nachdenken
zuckerberg zögerte weil er damit
beschäftigt war an einer ähnlichen
social network seite zu arbeiten die auf
dem studenten verzeichnis von harvard
basierte facebook er und service haben
sich zusammen um sie zu finanzieren
kam zu ihm und sagte was du investierst
1000 dollar
es gab keine verträge das waren wirklich
nur zwei kinder in einem schlafsaal
interviewte mehr als ein dutzend leuten
die an der gründung und facebook
beteiligt war und er entdeckte sofort
nachrichten die zuckerberg am semmering
geschrieben laut business insider deuten
die nachrichten an dass zuckerberg die
winklevoss-zwillinge bewusst in die irre
die interregio westwind er schrieb dinge
wie guck dir diese seite an harvard
connection hh wir haben einen fehler
gemacht die haben mich gebeten dass für
sie zu machen aber ich arbeite an meinem
eigenen facebook wir hatten immer den
eindruck dass markt an harvard
connection dot com arbeitet
ihm dass er das nicht tut oder nicht tun
wollte oder an etwas identischem
arbeitete auf der seite
als er sich das letzte mal mit den
winklevoss brüdern traf begriff er dass
er ihn wohl sagen sollte dass er an
einem konkurrenzprodukt saß er hat mit
freunden darüber gesprochen aber ende
sagte er weißt du was ich mache ich lass
sie abblitzen ich wirklich ab am 14
februar 2004 als er eigentlich ihre
seite fertig stellen sollte brachte
sascha burg mit seinen freunden
erfuhren war genauso wie fast alle
anderen
es hat uns komplett überrumpelt damit
haben wir nicht gerechnet
montag wollte die kontrolle über sein
eigenes projekt haben dass sie etwas
cooles vor hatten die winklevoss-brüder
aber er sagt dass er etwas kühleres
machen können jemanden vorgeht will er
für mich getan
facebook sorgte von anfang an für
kontroversen nur wenige tage nach dem
start im februar 2004 schickten ihn die
winklevoss zwillinge und die firma
wensauer eine unterlassungsaufforderung
er uns gesagt klagten wir gegen mark
zuckerberg wegen betrugs
ungerechtfertigter bereicherung und
vertragsbruchs
seine seite sei ein separates
unternehmen für uns
verwendeten später einen 65 millionen
dollar vergleich mit facebook an sie
verloren vor einem bundesgericht werk
sei dieser vergleich könnte jetzt 200
millionen dollar wert sein doch keines
dieser juristischen gerangel bremste sie
unglaubliche dynamik von facebook oder
facebook zu diesem zeitpunkt dachten
meine mitbewohner das ist ziemlich cool
ich lasse das wurde auch an anderen
schulen funktionieren
und innerhalb von wenigen wochen hatten
die tausende von nutzern und wir sagt
dann lass uns einfach mal gucken in wie
vielen spielen wie die seite noch so
schnell wie möglich starten können
zu diesem zeitpunkt begannen sie sich
mit risikokapitalgebern und größeren
werbetreibenden zu treffen
sie bekamen einen ziemlich grünen ziehen
mit visa und sie hatten einen deal mit
american express
sie hatten eine reihe von
werbetreibenden und gingen dann begannen
plattenfirmen sich zu interessieren und
sie erzielten ziemlich gute einnahmen
aus der musikindustrie
shawn parker seine eigene verbindung
musikgeschäft hat auf einer reise nach
new york zuckerberg und sein partner
mit dem 24-jährigen mitbegründer von
netzwerken zu abend diese nahmen
gestandene unternehmer und ein wirklich
kreativer außergewöhnlich interessanter
mensch der es ins netzwerk in silicon
valley geschafft hatte so dass man
einfach sterben könnte
severin war nicht einverstanden
von anfang an nicht viel von schon in
der dachte schon sein quacksalber sie
bräuchten die spucke große töne lebe
aber ausgesagt und sei
ausgeschlossen worden
wir haben zu beginn des jahres den start
150 weiteren schub
durch den wechsel nach palo alto -
wirklich in die petrischale der
unternehmen kik vor allem für neue
technologien zuckerberg und seine
freunde zogen in ein großes
fachwerkhauses schwimmbad und er traf
wieder auf sean parker der später borgs
mit
harris er war ein aufseher für
erwachsene diese gibt er ihm gezeigt hat
wie die dinge im silicon valley laufen
hieß robert ihnen gezeigt wie man
investoren trifft wie man mit ihnen
verhandelt und wenn man
hat mir geschichten von aldi muss
erzählt die spätnachts am esstisch harry
programmieren und chicken mcnuggets und
müsli essen
wo es wirklich schon parker bringt sie
zu den anderen coolen silicon valley
hotspots und währenddessen wächst die
website astronomischen ich meine im
dezember dieses jahres hatten sie eine 1
million mitglieder
kaka hat zuckerberg in dieser zeit viele
ratschläge gegeben war er sich zu herzen
nahm diese seien anderen sagte du musst
der gründer dieser sache sein du musst
immer der ceo sei was du kannst es nicht
an investoren ergebnis
und konnte einige sehr wichtige
investitionsabkommen aushandeln die zwei
dinge bewirken
sie gaben ihm genügend mittel um die
klügsten ingenieure der branche
einzustellen und zweitens er konnte die
mehrheit am unternehmen behalten
doch die spannungen mit seinem
ursprünglichen partner eduardo saverin
der an der ostküste geblieben waren
wurden immer größer
er fühlte sich als kaufmännischer leiter
des unternehmens wurde aber nicht nur so
behandeln und schon hat meetings in ganz
kalifornien ignoriert
und dann recht
aufmerksamkeit und markus
unternehmen
aufgebracht
hatte eine million aktive nutzer
universitäten im ganzen land und es
begann viel geld
tsonga der neue präsident von facebook
in stellte zuckerberg dem silicon valley
angel investor peter thiel vor der
500.000 dollar teures unternehmen stecke
im frühjahr 2005 bot die venture capital
gesellschaft texel partners sa camberg
12,7 millionen dollar für eine 11
sie wollten überhaupt nicht für
kontrolle kontrolliert er jetzt drei von
fünf vorstand sitzen
besaß ist eine bizarre und beispiellose
situation
wenn eine person die absolute
diktatorische kontrolle über die
aufstellung und leitung eines zunehmend
riesigen unternehmens hat
die excel investition brachte facebook
über nacht eine bewertung von 100
millionen dollar
mit dem öffentlichen profil von facebook
wuchs auch sascha brox machten thron
dieses mal wurde sean parker verdrängt
im august 2005 wurde er wegen des
verdachts des kokainbesitzes
löschen obwohl er nicht offiziell
angeklagt und sofort freigelassen wurde
würde diese zu seinem sofortigen
rücktritt
war der wichtigste repräsentant des
unternehmens aber man war der meinung
dass jemand der mit drogen zu tun hatte
nicht der richtige typ war um facebook
nach außen zu vertreten also stimmte
mark widerstrebend seiner entlassung zu
wuchs mit bemerkenswerter
geschwindigkeit und zuckerberg verlegte
das unternehmen von seiner studentenbude
mit dem pool in einen größeren und
konventionelleren raum in der innenstadt
von palo alto
college atmosphäre dieselbe
dass die kultur freundlich und die
läuterung in sachen verwaltung des
ganzen prozesses
nichts ich hab keine ahnung was ich tue
auch ihre mitarbeitergespräche waren
anders chris kelly wurde in der neuen
position des chief privacy officers
eingestellt um sich mit denen zunehmend
schwierigen datenschutz themen bei
facebook zu befassen so einer zeit als
das gesamte unternehmen nur ein paar
dutzend mitarbeiter
als ich mag zum ersten mal traf
kletterten wir durch das fenster auf
start und führten unser interview auf
dem dach eines weltverbesserung
was bisher passiert war irgendwo hin die
firma führung leute
entschlossen die ungewöhnlich kreative
kultur von facebook zu erhalten waren
programmieren echte eine möglichkeit das
zu tun wir haben diese meetings in der
firma wo alle zusammen kommen und
einfach zu trainieren die ganze nacht
was bahn und die einzige regel ist dass
man bei den treffen nicht an dem aber im
rat ansonsten
waren eines der kreativsten dinge die
man sich in einem unternehmen vorstellen
konnte da kommen diese unglaublich
talentierten ingenieure zusammen und
sagen wir bleiben die ganze nacht wir
programmieren einfach wir suchen uns ein
projekt aus und machen
das ist toll macht darf wir machen und
prototypen daraus dann gibt's ein krieg
und wir sehen wer gewinnt
vom aus marktsicht entstehen auf diese
weise gute ideen schnell und effizient
lässt kabel sehr gute ideen sonntag aber
führte etwas ein dass facebook einen
plötzlichen und dramatischen schub gast
es ermöglichte den leuten sich und ihre
freunde auf fotos zu identifizieren oder
zu markieren
das war eine riesige umstellung das
führte zu einer massiven neuen nutzung
von
facebook and photos waren sehr schnell
der bei weitem am meisten genutzte teil
von facebook facebook und der größte
wachstumstreiber
dieses wachstum ging in eine richtung
weiter nach oben laut facebook intern im
tracking wuchs die zahl der nutzer in
weniger als zwei jahren auf 5,5
millionen
mediengiganten kematen an die tür
2006 machte yahoo dem 22-jährigen
zuckerberg ein außergewöhnliches angebot
an bei auch für eine milliarde dollar an
dort noch außergewöhnlicher zuckerberg
lehnte ab
wenn sie eltern von jemandem in max
alter sind gucken sie sich die yahoo
entscheidung an und denken warum hast du
das geld nicht genommen
es ging nie um geld wenn es so wäre wäre
es einfach aus verkauft haben ich habe
einfach das gefühl das ist uns nicht
dabei helfen wurde facebook zu dem zu
machen was wir uns vorstellen
2006 lehnte mark zuckerberg einen
milliardenschweren pitch von yahoo als
mtv den einsatz noch
was
ich
hätte mir noch mark hatte mich auf einen
spaziergang durch palo alto mitgenommen
und mir seine wohnung gezeigt
dann gingen wir mittags und ich sagte
ihm dass wir bereit wären bis zu
anderthalb milliarden dollar zu zahlen
meine antwort war ist ich denke wir sind
viel mehr wert und außerdem hast du
meine wohnung gesehen drittel geld
brauche ich mit der parade money er
vielleicht habe ich nie wieder eine so
gute idee
ich will nicht wirklich
innere unruhen keine frage es gab viele
leute die verkaufen wollten uns markt
beschloss einfach diese angebote
abzulehnen
zuckerberg war noch nicht bereit zu
verkaufen weil er einige ideen hatte von
denen er dachte dass sie facebook noch
bekannter machen würden skoll eine von
ihnen hieß newsfeed eine art
echtzeitnachrichten ging es darüber was
die nutzer gerade tun
ist was jemand gerade tut oder was
apostel sind mit der welt verbindet in
der erlebt also etwas das eine zeitung
tut es ist eine lebendige atmende
zeitung von menschen um dich herum aber
viele facebook-nutzer dachten dass diese
zeitung zu viele informationen
verschickt und ihre privatsphäre
verletzt
750000 von demenz starteten einen online
protest zu sagen dass es unpopulär war
es eine dramatische untertreibung sie
wurden im büro belagert sie konnten
nicht gehört sie waren von reportern der
nutzer schlossen sich den studenten
gegen die facebook newsfeed gruppe an
so aber musste sich entschuldigen
er hat seine entschuldigung selbst
geschrieben es war wahrscheinlich eine
gute lernerfahrung als facebook einige
der datenschutz einstellungen ändern es
war eine überschreitung ich glaube er
nimmt das ernst aber ich glaube dass er
bereit ist weiter zu gehen um ein
produkt herzustellen dass er herstellen
möchte
die entschuldigung war keine
kapitulation
zuckerberg war sich sicher dass sich die
nutzer an diese neue art des teilens
gewöhnen würden und er behielt recht
hast du nach der optimierung des
newsfeed wurde es zu einem der
beliebtesten elemente
mit marc war zufällig zwei tage nachdem
das passiert war und ich kann ihnen
sagen obwohl seine mitglieder in aufruhr
waren war er nicht im geringsten
er hatte volles vertrauen dass alles gut
gehen würde
zuckerberg entschied dass es an der zeit
sei facebook über die uni grenzen hinaus
zu führen und der breiten öffentlichkeit
vorzustellen
die resonanz war die mitgliederzahl
verdoppelt und stieg bis 2006 auf 12
millionen
zuckerberg veränderte facebook erneut
radikal ins begehen weil es der 23
jährige programmierer aus aller welt
einlud amazon apps zu entwickeln die web
apps zu facebook es war ein weiterer
wendepunkt der facebook von einer
abgeschotteten informationswelt welche
einer plattform aus hatte
es war wie im goldrausch geöffnet diese
wundervolle plattform und alle möglichen
entwickler kommen mit einem möglichen
ideen von video sharing über spiele bis
die linken sich in ballerinas oder
nilpferde verwandeln und einfach jeder
art von lustigen sachen
oder betriebssystem unternehmen machen
immer das beste
microsoft hat diese allgegenwärtige
windows-plattform und all diese anderen
firmen haben programme für windows
geschrieben facebook versucht das licht
sich der selbst erschafft und
2007 brachte sich microsoft selbst
diesmal mit einem deal den zuckerberg
nicht ablehnen konnte und zum ersten mal
bekam die welt einen eindruck davon
leute gewöhnen sich daran dass jeder
eine milliarde dollar für facebook
bezahlen würde microsoft kommt und zahl
250 millionen dollar für 1,6 prozent des
unternehmens
das unternehmen wurde damit auf 15
milliarden dollar geschätzt das hat
facebook zu einer sache gemacht über den
alle redeten das 15 milliarden dollar
unternehmen aber für 1 15 milliarden
dollar unternehmen machte facebook nur
magere 30 millionen dollar gewinn
um dem abzuhelfen kündigte zuckerberg
ein umfassendes neues wertesystem ein
teil davon ermöglicht es unternehmen im
herbst 2007 ihre eigenen facebook seiten
1 und mit social fc lok körner
beschäftigt sich mit social media und
besitzt anteile an facebook
auf facebook sind anzeigen in denen
deine freunde mac und rein sagen dass
sie deutschen america mögen und es
überrascht nicht dass sie ist das deine
freunde ein produkt mögen das duo auf
diese anzeige klickt und so waren diese
social apps von anfang an sehr
erfolgreich von der bedenken aber ein
anderer teil des neuen werbe plans von
facebook bieten den nutzern weit mehr
als sie wollten und sie ließen
zuckerberg davon wissen
görg hat viele fehler gemacht bis der
nächste wirklich große fehler war bieten
du gehst auf eine e commerce seite eines
dritten täters in kauf wenn du nicht
schnellgang gebiss geht es zurück und
führt alle deine freunde darüber
informieren gerade einem diamant
verlobungsring gekauft es gab den riesen
auf schreibt dass facebook weihnachten
ruiniert hat weil plötzlich alle
einkäufe in ihr gesamtes netzwerk
übertragen wurden
wirklich eine weile versucht es zu
verteidigen es dauerte ein bisschen bis
er erkannte wie falsch es war im
dezember 2007 entschuldigte sich
zuckerberg erneut er hatte es wieder mal
übertrieben gern aber wie bei früheren
fehlern würde es nicht wirklich darauf
ankommen war einfach zu beliebt und es
dauerte nicht lange bis auch die
datenschutzbestimmungen des netzwerks
mehr als vier jahre seit der gründung
von facebook fühlte sich zuckerberg in
der öffentlichkeit immer noch zu
verkaufen sie
keins von den gerüchten das war oder
das ist mir sehr unangenehm bis 2009
kursierten gerüchte dass facebook
stattdessen nahm zuckerberg geld von
einem neuen investor
yuri milner geschäftsführer der
russischen internet investmentfirma
digital sky technologies
er bot einen 200 millionen dollar für
nur 1,9 prozent des unternehmens an
geschäfte dieser größenordnung sind nie
einfach ist gleich viel hin und her dass
der bei diesem deal ging es um die
vision die wir teilchen wie groß dieses
unternehmen werden
wilders investition ermöglicht es
facebook weiter zu expandieren die
entwicklung des unternehmens fest in den
händen des gründers in
der facebook werbung liegt der schlüssel
für weitere
glaubte jahre lang in einer
einzigartigen position sei
selbst mit den besten werbesystem die es
geht gibt es nur schätzungen geschlecht
alter oder interessen einer person aber
facebook wissen wir genau welches
geschlecht sie hat genau wie und genau
market ein unternehmen des aktien- und
privat gehaltene unternehmen vermittelt
die noch nicht am öffentlichen markt
gehandelt werden max facebook aus sicht
der werbetreibenden so begehrenswert
macht ist dass sie wie kein anderer
informationen über ihre nutzer sagen
kann das lustige ist dass die nutzer das
nicht wirklich als daten kraft sind sie
selbst es sind ihre informationen es ist
wir leben das sie doch veröffentlichen
[Musik]
dieses heiligen grabes brachte sascha
berg erneut in schwierigkeiten im
dezember 2009 überarbeitete er die
datenschutz einstellungen für die damals
350 millionen facebook-nutzer wenn die
nutzer ihre einstellungen nicht einzeln
wieder herstellten private informationen
jetzt für alle im internet verfügung
viele leute haben diese vorgabe einfach
übernommen und unbeabsichtigt zugelassen
dass ihre informationen veröffentlicht
werk und viele datenschützer glauben
dass sie das nicht erklärt oder
ausreichend offengelegt haben
ein feuersturm an beschwert von
anwendern und verbraucherverbänden zwang
zuckerberg erneut zurückziehen und löste
im kongress besorgnis aus wir sind heute
hier um den cio von facebook mark
zuckerberg aufzufordern die neue
richtlinie so schnell wie möglich zu
überdenken wir sind der meinung dass
facebook die richtlinien ändern sollte
damit die nutzer im voraus wissen was
passiert
das feuer noch weiter an instant
messages business insider
veröffentlichte nachrichten in denen ein
freund sascha burg polizei gefragt habe
warum die leute ihre e mails mit ihm
teilten seine antwort
ich habe ihm direkt danach gefragt
weniger als einen monat später wurde er
in einem denkwürdig peinlichen interview
bei der all things digital und die renz
gegrillt haben sie das gefühl die
privatsphäre anderer zu verletzen
wir haben beim aufbau viel gelernt
es gab echte wendepunkte
er nicht damals gewusst hätte was ich
heute weiß dann hätte ich die fehler
wohl nicht gemacht zurück in die
vergangenheit kann nur das tun was ich
für richtig
wer jemals daran gezweifelt hat worum es
bei facebook geht aber seine integrität
in frage stellen wollte kann sich immer
wieder darauf berufen oder
es wird unsere kontrolle über ihn sein
solange er ceo bleibt und das
unternehmen leitet es wird heißen ob du
bist nicht dieser typ weiß dass die
nicht dieser typ der
[Musik]
university of california berkeley glaubt
ihm als saccard geht beim datenschutz
gezielt an die grenzen prämisse muss in
den meisten situationen in denen ein
unternehmen etwas unpopulär das tut gibt
es einen rückschlag im sie verlieren die
fähigkeit etwas zu tun aber im fall von
facebook haben wir etwas das ich
wo sie zwei schritte nach vorne machen
es gibt eine öffentliche reaktion sie
treten nur einen kleinen schritt zurück
[Musik]
monaco ist der meinung dass man bei der
arbeit kein anderer mensch sein sollte
als auf der bowlingbahn im bett oder in
der schule er findet dass man in all
diesen umgebungen gleich sein sollten
ist das ist für viele ältere menschen
eine sehr radikale ansicht
als zuckerberg im jahr 2009 25 jahre alt
wurde lehrerteam war er so bekannt reich
mächtig
ihn und die gründung von
diese geschichte begann für mich in
einer e mail die ich aus heiterem himmel
bekannt
fühlte sich betrogen
gegen seinen ehemaligen herrschers
klassenkameraden eingereicht hatte
verbesserung von anteil am unternehmen
mit ihm sprach sie haben sich dann im
wesentlichen einig niemand weiß genau
was passiert ist aber ich habe gehört
dass er fünf prozent von facebook hat
und eine vereinbarung unterzeichnen
musste dass er nie wieder mit benders
wegbricht
mein vorschlag internet durchgesehen
hat es gesehen und
sofort an das drehbuch zu schreiben
die vorab werbung für den film sin
zuckerberg zu einer pr-offensive zu
drängen
der eigentlich so schüchterne zuckerberg
war plötzlich überall wenn dann etwas
großartiges macht interessiert dass die
leute das ist den leuten egal was jemand
in einem film über dich so 2010 gab er
oprah winfrey eine führung durch sein
haus und kündigte eine 100 millionen
dollar spende an schulen in newark new
jersey
100 millionen
[Applaus]
am ernst abbe 2010 kam der film des
sozialen netzwerk die leute wollen ins
internet gehen und ihre freunde schicken
warum also nicht eine website bauen die
das bietet die spreche davon die gesamte
soziale erfahrung der uni zu nutzen und
sie online zu stellen susak aber
beschwerte sich aber sein porträt auf
dem bildschirm als rücksichtsloser
sozial behinderter powervr ikone freunde
er sagte es gebe sachliche fehler im
drehbuch
das wäre der grund facebook zu machen
dass sich mädchen treffen will oder in
eine soziale einrichtung einsteigen will
aber die leute die mich kennen wissen
ich bin mit demselben mädchen zusammen
seit ich mit facebook angefangen habe
sie können sich einfach nicht mit der
vorstellung auseinandersetzen dass
jemand etwas bauen könnte weil einfach
gerne dinge baut
[Applaus]
obwohl er anfang sagte er würde sich den
film nicht ansehen kam zuckerberg am
ende mit seiner gesamten belegschaft er
tauchte so dabei hat er denn
jemals den film gesehen
ja
interessant
aber vieles ins tor das soziale netzwerk
gewann einen golden globe für das beste
drama
jetzt gekippten was kommt als nächstes
aber für immer mehr menschen auf der
ganzen welt war facebook nicht nur ein
hollywood
beeinflusste das wirkliche leben ende
2010 gingen demonstranten in tunesien
und später in ägypten auf die straße um
gegen die repressiven regierungen zu
protestieren von diesem zeitpunkt lebten
mehr als 70 prozent der über eine halbe
milliarde facebook-nutzer
in ägypten entzündete sich die wut an
einem fall von polizei
im mittelpunkt der proteste stand ein
google mitarbeiter der eine festlichkeit
betrieb
der manager einer seite in ägypten die
ein denkmal für einen typen war der von
der geheimpolizei geschlagen gefoltert
und getötet wurde
und diese gruppe wurde sehr sehr groß
viele viele hunderttausende von
mitgliedern während der zeit dieser
revolte gegen mubaraks führte
[Musik]
mit facebook konnten die menschen
schneller ihre unzufriedenheit
ausdrücken was den prozess diese wollten
deutlich beschleunigte
nachdem die regierungen von tunesien und
ägypten gestürzt waren potter dampften
sich demonstranten auf den straßen
facebooks einer nannte seine neugeborene
tochter facebook
ich würde gerne mark zuckerberg treffen
und ihm danken ich spreche im namen des
diese revolution begann auf facebook als
hunderttausende von ägyptern anfingen
informationen zusammen zu bringen
wenn wir ein video auf facebook posten
wurde es innerhalb weniger stunden von
50.000 menschen geteilt
facebook selbst hat versucht sich sehr
schnell von dieser politischen aktivität
zu distanzieren ich denke sie haben voll
unterstützt aber wollen nicht wirklich
als werkzeug dieser veränderung gesehen
facebook offensichtlich auch in ländern
wie china aktiv sein
sie wollen sich nicht als werkzeug des
aufstands
zuckerberg hat sich ein persönliches
ziel gesetzt sich bei seiner mission die
welt zu verbinden helfen könnte eine
stunde am tag chinesisch dabei helfen
könnte eine milliarde neuer freunde zu
gewinnen es ist der am schnellsten
wachsende und größte internetmarkt der
welt es gibt hunderte millionen von
nutzern und seine mission ist
unvollständig wenn er nicht denn china
ist mark zuckerbergs macht war nie
größer gewesen und wieder wuchsen die
spekulationen dass er sein unternehmen
an die börse bringen
in 102 100 jahren was wird dann
wichtiger sein das geld oder die
tatsache dass er diese art von einfluss
hatte oder die tatsache dass er dieses
ding gemacht und mit entwickelt hat mehr
ist das nur eine technologie sei
und es ist mehr als nur eine website und
deshalb ging es nie um geld
in unternehmen an die börse gehen ist
das eine enorme belastung für das
management und obendrein öffnet man sich
bei einem börsengang noch stärker der
staatlichen kontrolle
um diese kontrolle wissens verstärkte
facebook seine präsenz in roche von
seinem team dass mehrere ehemalige
berater des weißen hauses und
einflussreiche regierungsentscheidung
politische beamte werden dir sagen wenn
du soll der debatte nicht dabei bist
wirst du wahrscheinlich derjenige sein
der irgendwie ausgeschlossen
deswegen ist die anwesenheit in dieser
debatte vor allem wenn google yahoo
microsoft und viele andere große akteure
viel geld für lobbyarbeit ausgeben ein
fehler
klassenkameraden das unternehmen
verlassen um sich selbst
[Musik]
top programmierer verlassen unternehmen
wie google zu dem teil von facebook und
facebook und google die beiden internet
giganten mehr konkurrieren auf andere
weise
die beziehung zwischen ziemlich einfach
sie mögen sich einfach nicht aber sie
sind sehr verschieden
war irgendwie jung frech wild
und google ist wie ein algorithmus firma
aber sind typen die sind so für jedes
problem muss es einen weg geben einen
kleinen algorithmus zu schreiben der es
bewegt
es ist klar dass google den aufstieg der
sozialen netzwerke verpasst hat eric
schmidt hat zugegeben dass er auf
verlorenem posten steht sie haben eine
reihe von dingen ausprobieren das
soziale netzwerk war das einfach nicht
funktioniert im mai 2011 wurde facebook
in verlegenheit gebracht als bekannt
wurde dass es einen geheimen angriff auf
google gestartet hat
betreibt schadensbegrenzung nach der
enthüllung dass es eine pr firma
beauftragt hat negative geschichten über
google zu verbreiten fest behauptete
öffentlich das sei eine hetzkampagne
dabei der austausch zeigte die bösartig
die konkurrenz geworden war die ganze
nation katastrophe war wirklich nur ein
offener ausdruck der feindseligkeit
nicht nur zwischen beiden unternehmen
entstanden war dann fast ein
persönliches shakespeare drama das sich
zwischen google und facebook abspielt
auch viele ehemalige google
führungskräften sitzen die nicht nur
raketen als ihr früheres unternehmen zu
verdrängen
man kann nicht unterschätzen wie
ehrgeizig mark zuckerberg ist er sagt
seine mission ist es die welt offener
und zu einem besseren ort sonst für
seine mission ist es aber auch die
nummer eins zu sein ich glaube er will
auch jeanette eingraviert sein
weiteren harvard aussteiger zuckerberg
ein harter konkurrent im april 2012
besiegte er mit einer beeindruckenden
übernachten die rivalen google und
twitter
handumdrehen vom markt facebook mag die
photo sharing app so sehr dass es vor
dem börsengang eine milliarde dollar in
bar und aktien dafür bezahlt aber die
app ist kostenlos und hat kaum bekannte
einnahmen trotzdem braucht facebook
instagram vielmehr als instagram das
geld braucht instagram ist zu einem foto
sharing konkurrenten und einem eigenen
sozialen netzwerk geworden
facebook kann es nicht riskieren dass
ein anderes soziales netzwerk das auch
fotos ausgerichtet ist eine
vergleichbare anziehungskraft entwickeln
ich glaube dass das eine präventive
qualität google war mit ziemlicher
sicherheit auch interessiert und so war
facebook vielleicht gezwungen zu handeln
den bisher größten börsengang eines
internetunternehmens
das ist ein großartiger moment sehr zäh
im kapuzenpulli und turnschuhen verfügt
über 57 prozent
stimmrecht facebook hat buchstäblich die
welt verändert wir sind vom land über
das dorf in die stadt zu facebook das
glaube es wird immer größer und größer
und größer
für eine website die es geschafft hat
sich vom schlaf sei zu einer plattform
zu entwickeln auf der meine 80 jährige
mutter und ich und mein chiropraktiker
und meine dritte klasse zusammen kommen
was zu besprechen haben das ist eine
leistung
zuckerberg ist genau so visionär steve
jobs hier der sich als genauso
einflussreich erweisen wie bill gates wo
aber er hat es nicht mit einem spielzeug
zu tun
ein programm
sondern mit unserem leben unserer
identität deshalb glaube ich dass wir
ihm alle in gewisser weise in schach
halten müssen
wir treffen unsere entscheidungen bei
facebook nicht immer einen zu optimieren
was im nächsten jahr passieren würde
sondern um uns darauf vorzubereiten in
einer welt zu leben in der jede
produkterfahrung soziale alles von
facebook
[Musik]
während wir dieses nächste kapitel
beginnen habe ich viel über unsere
identität nachgedacht facebook ist eines
der meist genutzten produkte unserer
geschichte es ist eine einzigartige
social media bleibt aber sie
repräsentiert derzeit nicht mehr unser
gesamtes spektrum
instagram whatsapp messenger quest nun
auch von reisen nethery und mehr die
entwicklung unserer social media apps
wird immer ein wichtiger schwerpunkt für
uns sein aber im moment ist unsere marke
so eng mit einem einzigen produkt
verbunden dass sie unglücklich alles
repräsentieren kann was wir heute
geschweige denn in zukunft sein werden
ich hoffe dass wir mit der zeit als ein
meter versus unternehmen wahrgenommen
und ich möchte unsere arbeit unsere
identität auf das ausrichten worauf wir
hinarbeiten
wir haben gerade angekündigt dass wir
unser unternehmen grundlegend verändern
werden wir sehen unser geschäft
zukünftig in zwei verschiedenen
segmenten verteilt hat eines ist unsere
app familie und eines ist unsere arbeit
an zukünftigen plattform ist in diesem
zusammenhang ist es für uns an der zeit
eine neue unternehmensmarke einzuführen
die alles umfasst was wir tun die
widerspiegelt wer wir sind und was wir
aufzubauen hoffen ich bin stolz zu
verkünden dass unser unternehmen heute
zu meter wird
unsere mission ist nach wie vor
dieselben menschen über unsere apps und
ihren nagel zu verbinden daran wird sich
nichts ändern
auch sind wir immer noch das unternehmen
das technologie für den menschen und
seine umgebung gibt jetzt haben wir
einen neuen fix bringt der uns hilft das
mit diversen zum leben zu erwecken und
wir haben einen neuen namen der die
ganze bandbreite unserer arbeit und die
zukunft die wir mitgestalten wollen
wieder spielen von nun an wird das
metaversum und nicht allein facebook an
erster stelle stehen das bedeutet auch
dass sie in zukunft facebook nicht mehr
benutzen müssen um unsere anderen
diensten zu nutzen ich hoffe dass die
menschen unsere neue marke hat die
zukunft für die sie steht kennenlernen
werden in meinem studium habe ich
gelernt dass das griechische wort meter
darüber hinaus bedeutet für mich
symbolisiert es dass es immer mehr zu
entwickeln und zu entdecken gibt es gibt
immer ein nächstes kapitel in der
geschichte
von nun an wird facebook unter dem namen
meter bekannt sein es handelt sich aber
nur um eine namensänderung die
unternehmensstruktur bleibt mit der
ursprünglichen app familie erhalten
facebook messenger whatsapp und
instagram werden ihren namen beibehalten
und auf die gleiche weise funktionieren
auch das kürzel zum börsenticker wird
sich ändern und ab dem ersten dezember
auf meter verweisen es mag nur eine
namensänderung sein aber es ist bisher
facebooks größter schritt in die zukunft
und in richtung metaversum
diese riesige virtuelle welt in dem user
vor allem durch die verwendung des
opfers headsets eines virtual reality
oder auch augmented reality headsets
miteinander interagieren können wurde
auf der veranstaltung am donnerstag
angekündigt mark zuckerberg glaubt dass
das mittagessen vor allem die
weltwirtschaft ankurbeln wird
innerhalb des nächsten jahrzehnts wird
es mehr als eine milliarde menschen
erreicht haben und über mehr als 100
milliarden dollar an digitalen handel
verfügung es wird arbeitsplätze für
millionen von kreativen und entwickler
and schaffen
das unternehmen ist auf dem besten weg
im märz 20 21 einen umsatz von 120
milliarden dollar zu erzielen die
vorstellung dass das metaversum am ende
des jahrzehnts ein paar hundert
millionen dollar ausmachen wird lässt
erahnen wie weit der weg noch ist und
gibt uns ein gefühl dafür wie weit
facebook und deren technologie noch in
der entwicklung stehen
wir haben verschiedene anwendungsfälle
horizon plattform auf der sich nutzer in
einem interview bewegen erleben können
es ist nicht nur auf spiele beschränkt
obwohl neue titel und partnerschaften
auf der spielseite angekündigt worden
sondern es wurden auch anwendungen für
gesundheit und fitness für das ok das
headset vorgestellt in denen sich die
teilnehmer im virtuellen raum treffen es
gab auch anwendungen für den digitalen
handel bei denen geschäftstransaktionen
über virtuelle räume abgewickelt werden
mark zuckerberg meint es sei
umweltfreundlicher denn alle virtuellen
im metaversum abgewickelten geschäfte
sparen flüge und somit auch co2 der
bereich sonstiges und zahlungen machte
im dritten quartal dieses jahres 2 bis 3
prozent des umsatzes aus
peter hat noch einen weiten weg vor sich
hat aber seine investitionen bereits
verdoppelt die investitionsausgaben
werden wohl den geschäftsjahren 21 und
22 weiterhin stark ansteigen auch wird
will das geschäftsergebnisse mehr 2021
bereits um zehn milliarden dollar sinken
da facebook in reality apps investiert
hat was in zukunft ab q4 wohl ein
eigener posten für einnahmen sein wird
genau werden wir es wohl erst wissen wir
das geschäft wächst und das mit aversion
echte einnahmen und gewinn verzeichnen
noch vor ein paar stunden haben sie bei
einem unternehmen namens facebook
gearbeitet jetzt heißt es meter sie
ändern sogar den börsenticker das hat
selbst google nicht getan die mehrheit
des unternehmens arbeitet noch gar nicht
im metaversum warum also dieses risiko
eingehen
nun wir sehen es nicht als risiko an
denn wir kommen ja von einem unternehmen
das bereits alle hände voll zu tun hatte
die alle beim etat sind sehr aufgeregt
und blicken begeistert in die zukunft
die wir gemeinsam mit unserem
unternehmen gestalten wollen auch unsere
mission hat sich nicht geändert metas
fokus liegt zwar auf dem aufbau des
metaversum es aber auch weiterhin darauf
menschen miteinander zu verbinden
gemeinschaften zu bilden und unternehmen
in ihrem wachstum zu unterstützen so wie
wir es bei facebook bereits seit fast 20
jahren tun
es wurde zeit dieser riesigen familie an
apps einen eigenen namen zu geben denn
auch wenn alles mit facebook begann ist
es doch über die zeit gewachsen und der
name stand nun nicht mehr für eine app
sondern für eine ganze reihe von
einzigartigen apps wie whatsapp oder
instagram diese ganzen technologien
bringen wir nun unter einen namen einer
brandneuen unternehmensmarke zusammen
geben sie uns ein paar informationen
darüber wie der horizon marktplatz
aussehen wird wird er die ein app store
funktionieren wird es ein abo modell
geben wie werden die menschen damit in
zukunft geld verdienen
eine menge fragen fangen wir bei horizon
an damit stellen wir den menschen eine
soziale plattform zur verfügung mit der
sie im metaversum kreieren und
interagieren können mitreisen worlds
können sie welten erschaffen in denen
sie mit ihren freunden ihrer familie
oder ihren kolleginnen eintauchen und
neue orte entdecken können sie können
sich dort treffen spiele spielen oder
verschiedene mitglieder ihrer
gemeinschaft mit verschiedenen avatar
kennenlernen
horizon home ist unsere erste vision für
ein virtuelles zuhause im metaversum und
wird eine erweiterung zu den bereits
verfügbaren horizon workgroups sein erst
letzte woche war ich in einem virtuellen
meeting und das gefühl das man hat wenn
man zusammen an einem virtuellen tisch
sitzt ist ein ganz anderes besonders in
der heutigen zeit in der wir alle viel
online oder remote arbeiten man hat
tatsächlich das gefühl dass man zusammen
an einem tisch sitzt man dreht den kopf
und sieht seine kolleginnen es ist ein
ganz anderes publikum
es ist ein erweitertes soziales erlebnis
wenn man so will
was aber wenn das metaversum e.on und
wie all die welt gar nicht sozialer
machen wenn sie uns isolierter und
unsozialer machen also viele dieser
kritikpunkte mit den facebook
konfrontiert war
nun diese erfahrung habe ich persönlich
nicht gemacht als ich mich im virtuellen
raum mit leuten getroffen oder spiele
gespielt habe meine kolleginnen und ich
wir waren auf dem mond und haben self es
mit unseren avatar gemacht im
hintergrund waren die sonne und die
sterne zu sehen
ich denke aber dass der kern ihrer frage
darauf abzielt wie wir als firma
sicherstellen dass wir uns mit dem
metaversum dass wir bauen
verantwortungsvoll auseinandersetzen und
ich denke es gibt ein paar dinge die
besonders wichtig sind
erstens das metaversum wird nicht von
einem unternehmen alleine erschaffen
viele verschiedene firmen eine menge
unterschiedlicher entwickler innen von
anderen unternehmen werden gemeinsam
daran arbeiten
auch ist es sehr wichtig von anfang an
grundsätze über die sicherheit um moral
einzubeziehen wenn wir die grundsätze
unserer gesellschaft auch hier
beherzigen können wir viel besser mit
den neuen herausforderungen umgehen die
unweigerlich mit den neuen technologien
entstehen werden
die facebook fans haben einige der
missstände in den sozialen medien
aufgedeckt facebook waren diese probleme
bekannt wurden aber aus sicht der
öffentlichkeit nicht streng genug
angegangen instagram zum beispiel ist
gerade für teenager sehr gefährlich nur
weniger als fünf prozent der
hasserfüllten inhalte wurden aber
tatsächlich entfernt stellt sich
facebook nun dieser wirklichkeit oder
ist es eher eine flucht verpflichtet
sich meter für diese probleme die
verantwortung zu übernehmen
wissen sie es wird gerade sehr
koordiniert versucht durch selektiv
veröffentlichte dokumente ein falsches
bild unseres unternehmens zu zeichnen
und das spiegelt wirklich in keiner
weise das unternehmen wieder das ich
kenne das mir am herzen liegt und für
das ich gerne arbeite ich bin wirklich
stolz darauf dass wir diese schweren
kompromisse die damit verbunden sind so
gut gemeistert haben
schauen sie sich die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen und die erheblichen
investitionen an die wir getätigt haben
wenn wir uns nur mal dieses jahr
anschauen wir haben mehr als fünf
milliarden dollar für die sicherheit
ausgegeben mehr als jedes andere
technologie-unternehmen auch wenn man
sich die größenordnung ansieht von der
wir sprechen wir beschäftigen heute mehr
als 40.000 mitarbeiter in allein für die
sicherheit des unternehmens
dies zeigt dass wir nicht weglaufen
sondern die verantwortung die wir hier
haben absolut ernst nehmen und diesen
fortschritt können sie in allen
bereichen unseres unternehmens sehen
[Musik]
aber es sind 40 tausend angestellte die
drei milliarden nutzer in betreuen ist
meter denn in der lage diese
herausforderung zu meistern
es mag ja sein dass es dort viele kluge
und fähige mitarbeiter in gibt aber
können sie jedes politische moralische
und religiöse thema auf der ganzen welt
und in jeder sprache bewältigen oder ist
das für jedes einzelne unternehmen
einfach schier unmöglich
unter anderem haben wir uns vorgenommen
unsere arbeit in diesem bereich sehr
offen und transparent zu halten aus
diesem grund veröffentlichen wir jetzt
vier mal im jahr den community standards
enforcement report und stellen ernst &
young unsere geschäftsberichte zur
verfügung damit diese in der lage sind
völlig unabhängig unsere ergebnisse zu
betrachten und zu validieren
darauf können wir wirklich stolz sein
denn ich denke dies ist eine der
umfassendsten und anspruchsvollsten
herausforderungen die wir derzeit
umsetzen aber um ihre frage zu
beantworten
wir können natürlich nicht zufrieden
sein wenn es auf unserer plattform etwas
gibt das in irgendeiner weise jemandem
schaden könnte wir werden uns also
weiterhin dafür einsetzen dass so etwas
von unserer plattform verschwindet wir
werden vielleicht nicht jeden schaden
verhindern können aber wir sind fest
entschlossen alles in unserer macht
stehende zu tun um solche fälle so
gering wie möglich zu halten im moment
ist facebooks werbeanzeigen geschäftjahr
der treibende motor für das wachstum in
der branche wir haben gesehen dass
facebook twitter und snap aufgrund der
änderungen der apple werbe tracking
technologie einbußen hinnehmen mussten
apple gibt heute seine
geschäftsergebnisse bekannt und wie es
scheint haben sie ihre schätzungen für
das vierte quartal verfehlt als jemand
der so viel einfluss auf das werbe
anzeigen geschäft besitzt könnten sie
uns ein paar worte dazu sagen
wir haben schon lange vor apples ios 14
politik gewandt und vor der tatsache
dass sie in wirklichkeit den eigenen
gewinn auf kosten von urheberinnen und
kleineren unternehmen begünstigt hat und
wir sehen dass das jetzt der fall ist
vor allem kleinere unternehmen die über
sehr niedrige budgets verfügen die
müssen in der lage sein ihre kundinnen
die für sie wichtig sind zu erreichen
und gerade im letzten jahr haben wir
gesehen wie wichtig dies für junge
unternehmen war die ihre läden nicht für
ihre kundinnen öffnen konnten im grunde
glauben wir dass datenschutz und werbung
weiterhin gut vereinbar sind auch ohne
den von apple verursachten
kollateralschaden
es kamen fragen zum absacker bergs
zukünftige rolle im unternehmen auf ich
bin gespannt ob es anzeichen dafür gibt
dass er als ceo zurücktritt um
vielleicht in den vorstand zu wechseln
wie es larry und sergej bei google getan
haben vielleicht gibt es auch
überlegungen dass sharon eine andere
rolle übernehmen wird oder einen schritt
zurücktreten wird wenn das werbeanzeigen
geschäfte metaversum jetzt eher eine
untergeordnete rolle spielt
niemand behauptet dass unser
werbeanzeigen geschäft in zukunft nicht
mehr so wichtig sein wird es ist
weiterhin ein wichtiger teil unseres
geschäfts und ich wünschte sie hätten
mag und scherrer auf der konferenz auf
der wir gerade präsentiert haben erleben
können die begeisterung die nicht nur
von sheryl sondern von allen unseren
führungskräften im unternehmen ausging
alle waren begeistert und hatten spaß
unsere vision der nächsten jahrzehnte zu
testen und zu teilen
nicola als jemand der so entscheidend am
globalen werbeanzeigen geschäft
beteiligt ist welche möglichkeiten für
zukünftige kampagnen sehen sie im
metaversum die effektiv wird ihrer
meinung nach das add on getting dort
sein und wie glauben sie können
werbetreibende davon profitieren
ich denke dass es viele neue und
aufregende möglichkeiten für
werbetreibende im metaversum geben wird
es wird sich vieles und metaversum
weiterentwickeln sowie sich vieles heute
im internet weiter entwickelt aber die
art und weise mit der wir unsere
produkte und werbemöglichkeiten
entwickeln wird bleiben wir beginnen
beim menschen und stellen sicher dass
sie unsere produkte zu 100 prozent
verstehen und nutzen können
ich denke es wird eine menge
möglichkeiten für entwickler innen und
nutzer innen geben wir werden dafür
sorgen dass es genügend tools geben wird
damit man auch im metaversum erfolgreich
sein kann es gibt also viel worauf man
gespannt sein kann wir sehen bereits
unternehmen die anfang mit augmented
reality zu experimentieren ich denke da
zb an den virtuellen ravens tor der es
einem auf instagram erlaubt
sonnenbrillen anzuprobieren oder der
shop von charlotte marie in dem make-up
und lippenstifte ausprobiert werden
können
wir sehen also dass manche marken
anfangs spaß daran zu haben
sie führen jeden tag eine menge
gespräche mit werbetreibenden deshalb
möchte ich sie fragen ob sie sich sorgen
um den ansteigenden rummel auf sozialen
medien machen machen sie sich sorgen
über zukünftige behauptungen oder
enthüllungen von whistleblowern wie zb
jetzt erst frances augen denn die
kritiker fragen sich natürlich ob man
werbung auf einer plattform wie facebook
heutzutage noch rechtfertigen kann
ja also alle gespräche die ich mit
unserem partner in bisher führte waren
fundiert und gut durchdacht sie schätzen
unseren cleveren ansatz die
investitionen die wir tätigen und die
beträchtlichen fortschritte die wir im
laufe der jahre gemacht haben
sie erkennen sehr wohl wie information
aus dem zusammenhang gerissen werden und
warum es für ein unternehmen richtig ist
seine eigenen produkte zu analysieren um
sie ständig zu verbessern
unsere kundinnen verstehen dass das ein
wichtiger bestandteil unserer arbeit ist
und sehen auch unser engagement in
organisationen wie beim oder amnesty zu
der wir auch stehen
sie sind nur ein grund von mieters
präsentationen oder
auf jeden fall und es ist natürlich
viele investorinnen wird diese
präsentation begeistert haben solch eine
vision von einem unternehmen zu sehen
das einen jahresumsatz von über 120
milliarden dollar besitzt
mark zuckerberg ist tatsächlich
innovativ und sehr visionär wenn es
darum geht sein unternehmen auf die
nächste stufe zu heben es wird auch sehr
schwer werden das alles umzusetzen
[Musik]
es wäre natürlich einfacher gewesen
diesen schritt in einem früheren stadium
zu wagen als facebook noch etwas jünger
war sie haben sehr erfolgreich vom
desktop aufs handy geschafft und dann
vom handy auf instagram aber die
skeptiker fragen sich natürlich wie sie
diese ganzen inhalte auf die plattformen
bringen wollen
für die demo hatten sie ja grand theft
orgel metaversum gezeigt aber das ist
nur ein spiel es geht ja darum ein
ganzes ökosystem aufzubauen und wirklich
alles im sinne der kreativwirtschaft
zusammenzubringen das ist für ein
erwachsenes unternehmen sehr viel
schwieriger wenn man außerdem mit einem
großen vertrauens problem zu kämpfen hat
und genau da sehe ich die
herausforderung aber man muss auch sehen
dass diese vision ja auf die nächsten
zehn jahre ab
schritt für schritt wird es möglich sein
kerngeschäft und transformationen zu
vereinbaren ich denke bei fast drei
milliarden nutzer hin ist das der
richtige weg
[Musik]
mandy ich glaube es was gott kessler der
verhinderer hingewiesen hat dass
facebook heute die marke mit den wohl
negativsten assoziationen der geschichte
ist soll uns meter von all den problemen
und dem negativen der vergangenheit
ablenken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie werden sich natürlich auf ihre
bisherigen methoden zur nutzung von
daten konzentrieren dennoch sind sie
immer noch ein sehr innovatives
unternehmen was alles für die nächste
große technologie welt aber wie ich
bereits sagte denke ich dass die größte
herausforderung natürlich in der größe
des unternehmens liegt erst recht wenn
der fokus hier nun komplett auf das
metaversum verschoben wurde
[Musik]